des chars russes aux abords de l'usiné
azote stahl
depuis hier ils donnent l'assaut sur le
complexe métallurgique derniers bastions
tenus par les ukrainiens mario paul ces
dernières semaines lusine été pilonnée
uniquement par l'aviation et la marine
russe
les troupes sont désormais au sol elles
tiennent déjà certaines positions de
cette immense usine
il ya notre position et 6 est sur la
gauche du côté de la mer on voit toute
l'usiné
comme vous le constatez tout brûle notre
artillerie est en action
ces images tournées par la télévision
russe montre l'ampleur des destructions
sur plusieurs bâtiments
quelques journalistes ont pu suivre les
militaires russes à mario paul cette
usine date de l'époque soviétique et a
été construite pour résister à une
attaque nucléaire il ya plusieurs
niveaux de sous sols des civils peut
être 200 seraient encore retrancher dans
les entrailles de lusine dans l'attenté
d'une évacuation comme celle ci qui a eu
lieu le week-end dernier des images
filmées par les combattants d'ukrainiens
je veux aller n'importe où en ukraine
nous combattrons terreau et sous
d'intenses bombardements pendant des
semaines certains n'y croyaient plus il
imaginait le pire
hier les dernières personnes évacuées
ont pu rejoindre la ville de zaporijia
après avoir été contrôlé par l'armée
russe
ils nous ont mis dans une tente on a dû
enlever nos vêtements puis ils ont
vérifié nos documents et et scanner nos
téléphones
sur cette vidéo de propagande diffusée
par les séparatistes pro-russes on voit
la violence des combats de ces dernières
semaines sur l' usine d'azov star